اسرعوا بلغ الثروه القوات الروسيه فجرت عن
طريق الخطا دبابه لمقاتليزاجنر خبر نقلته
الصحيفه روسيه بين مهاجم عناصر
فاجنرغيراسي موفا بالاسم اتهموه بتفضيله
وحداتي الجيش اثناء توزيع الذخيره بينما
يقاتلون وحدهم من اجل باخوط القتال فيه
بخموط واسوليدار غير من شكل بروكسيل في
عيون الروس دعايه ايجابيه كما تحدث البيت
الابيض لما يعد مجرد اخر تعتبر علاقته
بفوتنا السره نجاحه الوحيد وتحت صدى
شعبيته اعترف الكرام بانجازات ذات نهار
وسطها بالبطوليه خبره القاده وولاء الجنود
لفاغنر التي منحتهم فرصه ثانيه للحياه لم
يكن وحدهما السبب فبروجين لديه روايته
الخاصه وبغض النظر عن المستقيمتها كانت
تبدو على انها
احصاء لنقاط ضعف الجيش
الروسيه الذي لم يتاقلم مع الظروف
تنور بشكل اكبر ودائم ولا تستقر طويلا في
مكان واحد ولا وجود لكلمه قاعده في قاموس
فاجنر سبب تكتكيا اخر جاء على لسان احد
مقاتلها
نحن عكس البقيه لا نقتحم المدن بهدف
السيطره عليها في البدايه نعمل على
التطبيق المدينه وقطع خطوط الامداد
والاتصال فقد عندما يصبح مركز المدينه تحت
مرمى مدفعيتنا نقدحم شوارعها